damen und herren der versuch geben
begriff des geistes in der psychologie
nachzugehen der dieser
ein schwieriges unterfangen war sicher
der ausdruck geist auch an vielen
stellen in adornos bergauf aber sind
immer wieder andere kontexte in denen er
verwendet wird und außerdem lässt sich
der ausdruck wenn wir uns für die
heutigen zwecke auf dasjenige
beschränken was bei hegel noch
subjektiver geistige wohl nur in seinem
zusammenhang mit einer reihe anderer
begriffe die bewusster ein subjekt
vernunft oder auch individuum erläutern
im wort geist so adorno kann die
erinnerung an individuelle subjektivität
nicht getilgt werden
das ist auch schon eine seiner zentralen
teststellungen das kalt ist kann gar
nicht gedacht werden oder sich auf
vergesellschaftet und sinnlich offizier
bahre individuen zu beziehen
doch der reihe nach um die konturen von
adonis geist begriff zu vergegenwärtigen
beschäftige ich mich zunächst mit seiner
kritik an idealismus mit seiner
auseinandersetzung an dem dort
vorherrschen mit den dort
vorherrschenden thema begeistern
gegen den vorrang des objekt klargemacht
wird die zweiten teil des vortrags
diskutiere ich dann adornos konzeption
geistiger erfahrung auch hier ein
durchaus positiver wirkung ein aktiver
bezug auf den geist was das thema krise
betrifft da würde ich sagen adorno
versucht dem bleibt in der krise nach
der krise wieder auf die beine zu helfen
indem er einen modifizierten begriff des
geistes anbietet im letzten teil des
vortrags versuche ich dann adornos
überlegungen zur frage stellung
innerhalb der neueren vorrangig
analytisch geprägten philosophie des
geistes in beziehung zu setzen
erster teil idealismus kritik eine ganz
eklige gelenk stelle von adornos
philosophieren stellt die beschäftigung
mit der philosophie des deutschen
idealismus da insbesondere mit kant und
hegel die pointe diese
auseinandersetzung liegt darin dass
adorno nicht nur kritisiert sondern auch
hier mit kant korrigiert mit hegel macht
dagegen kannte
ist dieser von einer zu statischen
gegenüberstellung von subjekt und objekt
ausgeht und eine stihl gestellte form
von erkenntnistheorie betreibt mit kalt
macht dagegen geltend dass die objekte
und inhalte der erfahrung denn subjekt
gegenüber eine eigenständigkeit besitzen
nichts wert vom geist bzw subjekt
überformt gedacht werden würden und
gegen beide gegen kant und hegel macht
er überdies und letztlich mit markt und
der psychoanalyse geltend dass geist und
subjekt nicht als erste sein können sie
nicht von der welt losgelöst sind
sondern ihrerseits in materielle von
zügen soziale und natürliche art
eingebettet sind die idealistische
philosophie verkennt mit ihrem geiste
brief der wind jetzt adornos
formulierung das ineinander von apriori
und gesellschaft sowie vom geist und
leib haften impuls adornos der den
materialismus den idealismus aber nicht
einfach entgegen als philosoph bleibt er
in einem bestimmten sinn ideal ist weil
er der auffassung ist dass alles
philosophie von sich aus idealistisch
ist das ist bereits innerhalb der fall
was wir dürfen mit begriffen operieren
müssen sie können keine stoffe oder etwa
20 begrifflich ist sie können kein wie
adorno einmal bemerkt kein stück seien
bis in ihre philosophischen texte hinein
kleben an adornos sind recht
verstandener materialismus gehört zu
einem recht verstandenen idealismus dazu
man muss die beiden positionen zusammen
ziehen sie miteinander vermitteln
idealismus im herkömmlichen sinn wird zu
einer donald variante einer verfehlten
art von ursprungs philosophie angesehen
im rahmen derer alles aus einem prinzip
zurückgeführt wird im idealismus ist es
das subjekt der geist das
beziehungsweise der sich alles in der
welt angleicht
madonna schreibt im zusammenhang
einer charakterisierung des idealismus
riskieren dass identifizierende prinzip
gar keine vereinheitlicht und alles was
da ist die welt gleich wird ist aber
immer auf der subjekte seite eine solche
einheit gibt es anders als vermittelt
durch die subjektivität überhaupt nicht
zitat ende
in der passage hitzler vom subjekt
beziehungsweise von subjektivität die
rede
aber die ausdrücke subjekt und geist
spiel in der realistischen philosophie
adorno zufolge der tendenz nach die
selbe rolle so dass er die begriffe
sogar einfach füreinander austauscht so
heißt es in der negative dialektik zitat
hegel inhaltliche philosophieren hatte
zum fundament und resultat den primat
des subjekts dass bestimmte einzelne war
vom geist bestimmbar bei seine immanente
bestimmung nicht anderes als geil sein
sollte und dann heißt es weiter geben
sich zu den idealismus ist die post das
ist des geistes und eine vernunft die
sich selbst zum geist verabsolutiert
alle zitate aus der negative dialektik
obwohl alles gar nicht anders als durch
das objekt beziehungsweise den geist
vermittelt werden kann möchte adorno die
verabsolutierung des geistes korrigieren
der jetzige geliftet geleistet so meint
er sei ergebnis einer abstraktion von
sieben einzelner individuen von denen er
aber letztlich nicht unabhängig gedacht
werden könne
und außerdem sei es ein versuch der
subjekt der erkenntnistheorie zu einem
ganzen zu machen
der aber in der gefahr stehe die welt
aus den augen zu verlieren
in tat negative dialektik vergebens die
post basiert higl den geistigen zuwege
zu bringen
zum ganzen aufgehen während geist auf
seinem begriff nach seiner differenzen
spezifika daran hat dass er subjekt also
nicht das ganze ist geist der totalität
sein soll ist nonsens die taktik gegen
hegel jedes adorno darum den begriff des
geistes in einer weise zu erläutern
welche darauf fehlt die verbindung nicht
gehalten mit der welt der natur der
materie
häufig zu machen so dass die welt nicht
aus den augen verloren sondern im blick
verhalten wird vorrang des objekts so
lautet die formulierung die in diesem
zusammenhang immer wieder verwendet wird
mit der rede vom vorgang des objekts
fall ist adorno die realistische
positionen im herkömmlichen sinn und
versucht jede den wahren kern des
materialismus zu in kooperieren
der matjes muss sich ihm zufolge gerade
dadurch aus dass er den geist zitat die
rechnung präsentiert in dem er den geist
seiner eigenen natur nützlichkeit
überführt und schließlich dem ursprung
des gleitens und nach seiner äußersten
sublimierung in der lebensmitte sucht
zitat ende
der geist ist dass deutschland gerade
nicht frei von den verstrickungen in
diese langes leben als welchen der
idealismus ihm präsentiert ich würde
adorno und so verstehen dass der gegen
regelt identität philosophie die von
einem flächendeckenden thematisch greift
es ausgeht ein begriff des geistes zu
formulieren versucht mit dem genau die
rettung eines primat nicht verbunden ist
stattdessen sucht er nach spuren von
materialität die den guide ihrerseits
bedingungen ohne dass sich dieser oder
die subjektivität darin auflösen würden
beziehungsweise darauf reduzieren ließen
und aus der einsichtige bedingtheit des
geistes werden letztlich zwei
konsequenzen gezogen eine eher
erkenntnistheoretische art eine andere
die der philosophie des geistes in
engeren sinne zugehört denn die
theoretische konsequenz bezieht sich
darauf dass die dinge und sachverhalte
in der welt auf robuste weise von geist
unabhängig sind gedanken müssen sich auf
eine geist unabhängige realität beziehen
und die gedanken sein zu können die sie
sind unsere erkenntnis der welt decken
was in ihr ist muss von der welt
abhängen
wir können von der welt nicht denken
oder glauben was wir wollen
die welt muss unsere überzeugung auf
eine rationale weise beschränken
adorno
wendet sich gegen den idealismus sofern
dieser die welt aus dem blick zu
verlieren drohen geld hat sich immer an
etwas abzuarbeiten was ihm vorgegebenen
er bedarf der objekte adorno zitiert vom
subjekt objekt nicht einmal als idee
wegzudenken
die talente der zeit dass der geist nur
vermögen der objekte ist was er isst er
bleibt als solcher aber in ihnen
enthalten ohne die objekte darum jedoch
ganz an die anzugleichen noch ein zitat
objekt kann nur durch subjekt gedacht
werden
er hält sich aber diesen gegenüber immer
als andere
zitat ende es ist genau dieser aspekt
den adorno zufolge strikt idealistische
positionen übersehen
der geist hat sich von den objekten
bestimmen zu lassen und sie so zu
erkennen wie sie sind und diese nicht
über formen oder nur nach maßgabe der
eigenen belange anzusehen die bestimmung
durch die objekte wird bei adorno aber
nicht als ein rein kausalen gesehen
gedacht die rißtissen theorien der
erkenntnis zum bestimmt werden durch die
objekte gehört vielmehr eine verfassung
des geistes die es erlaubt sich
bestimmen zu lassen
letztlich wird und das macht die sache
komplizierter eine utopie der erkenntnis
formuliert bevor ich diesen gedanken
weiter ausführen indem ich nicht mit
adorno verfahrens betrifft
auseinandersetzen möchte ich noch etwas
zu der zweiten konsequent sagen der
dorna aus der einsichtigen bedingtheit
des geistes zieht diese konsequenz
betrifft den umstand dass der geist
etwas ist was vom körperlichen
durchdrungen ist
in der negative dialektik heißt es dazu
zitat tätigkeit geistes einmal
vermenschlicht kann niemand und nichts
anderem zugesprochen werden als im
lebendigen dann infiltriert noch den
begriff der überall naturalismus am
lösten hinaus schießt gegen der
subjektivität mit dem natur moment zitat
ende
und wenig später macht adorno deutlich
alles geistige ist modifiziert lebhafter
impuls die gegenüberstellung von geist
und körper beziehungsweise von geist und
natur ist
folgt man adorno ebenso fasziniert wie
die frage danach falsch gestellt ist was
primär ist wer von einem dualismus von
geist und körper ausgeht macht den geist
zitat zum schlechten anderen des körpers
im widerspruch zu seinem immanent
somatischen zitat ende und wer die frage
stellt was als erstes berger nuss
verkennt dass das eine ohne das andere
nicht sein kann
ich habe diese konsequenz als der
philosophie des geistes im engeren sinne
zugehörige bezeichnen weil der
traditionelle begriff des geistes hier
durch eine markante veränderung erfährt
adorno geht es hier nicht nur um eine
entwicklungsgeschichte
er nimmt nicht nur eine genetische
perspektive ein
wenn er schreibt drang geht die vorform
von leid und bemerkt dass vernunft sich
genetisch aus der trieb energie als
während differenzierung entwickelt hat
es geht nicht immer darum wie diese
formulierung nahelegen dass ich geist
aus der natur entwickelt hat sondern
dass natur im geist bzw
das greift auch natur ist und das ist
eine begriffs logische behauptung mit
diesen überlegungen macht sich adorno
jedoch nicht für eine die potenzierung
des geistes stark wie man vielleicht in
der nachfolge - wobei man das vielleicht
nach dem vortrag heute morgen ein wenig
relativieren muss
dollar nachdem sie ebenfalls mich für
eine potenzierung des geistes stark
ziehen erzählt er darauf ein begriff des
geistes zu formulieren der dessen
natürliche bedingtheit akzentuiert diese
nicht zu kaschieren versuchte sondern
mit hinzu dessen und hier zeigt sich
einmal mehr der utopische charakter von
adornos transformationen
erkenntnistheoretische fragen mit hilfe
dessen eine versöhnung mit der eigenen
natur angeführt werden soll
dieser aspekt ist in ihren autos
freiheit leben und wird mit der
kategorie des hinzutreten betonte er in
kontakt zu einer meta kritik der
praktischen vernunft im vorwahlkampf
gewidmeten teil der negative dialektik
dazu nur so viel die pointe der
freiheits wäre 60 ohne adornos begriff
des geistes der mit dem körper im sinne
einer lebendigen natur zusammen gehört
gar nicht verstehen so vernünftigen
einsicht so macht adorno geltend gehören
nämlich körperliche impulse die den
geist nicht äußerlich bin sondern sie
sind zitat adorno im tram mental und
somatischen 1 im zusammenhang mit der
rede vom vorrangig objekt hatte ich oben
davon gesprochen dass adorno eine utopie
der erkenntnis formuliert was ist damit
gemeint
die philosophie von der hat dort träumt
ist eine in der man mit begriffen über
begriffe hinaus gelangt und auf diese
weise die welt erreicht und in diesem
zusammenhang spielt der geist bzw
spielen geistige tätigkeiten eine
wichtige rolle
damit bin ich beim zweiten teil des
vortrags begriffs kritik und geistige
erfahrung zu den gravitationszentrum von
hat eine philosophie gehört ohne zweifel
seine begriff kritik an vielen stellen
seines werkes artikuliert er den
gedanken das begriffliche denken immer
vereinfachende identifikationen der
diemel nach sich zieht vorbei ein einmal
identifiziertes etwa wenn in der regel
auf einen einzigen fan aspekte reduziert
wird immer wieder spricht adorno vom
abschneiden oder zu rüsten charakter der
begriffe gelegentlich auch vom schein
charakter begriffe erkennen jetzt das
alte formulierung die auf die aufwands-
und hinauszulaufen dass die begriffliche
sprache keine adäquate erfassung der
wirklichkeit beziehungsweise der liga
sind rede stehende gegenstand bereiche
ermöglicht sondern im gegenteil zu
verwerten und verglichen den
auffassungen des wirklichen führt
wirklich verstanden sehen die
formulierung so aus als mit ihnen für
einen ausstieg aus der philosophie
verliert man sollte adornos begriffs
kritik jedoch jedoch nicht im sinne ein
belgier für einen ausstieg aus der
philosophie verstehen sondern wie in
einem schwächeren sinne interpretieren
in einem bringen
der erlaubt zwischen einem verfehlten
verständnis unserer begriffe und einem
angemessenen umgang mit ihnen zu
unterscheiden
erkenntnis ist adorno zufolge immer
begrifflich und eine der wichtigsten
fragen die seien gängige greift lautet
wie das vorher geht anzusetzen
zwischen begriffen und ihm nicht
begrifflichen die nicht identischen
derzeit die nicht mit dem begriff
identischen und eine antwort darauf gibt
seine konzeption geistiger erfahrung
trotz aller kritik an greif begriff des
idealismus und das objekt betrifft der
erkenntnistheorie gehört zur geistigen
erfahrung in adornos in nicht weniger
sondern mehr subjekt der begriff der
geistigen erfahrung kommt in der
negative dialektik insgesamt neun mal
vor und auch an anderen stellen seines
werkes und diese betrifft und eine reihe
weiterer mit adjektiven wie unreguliert
subjektiv philosophisch oder auch
metaphysisch qualifizierte erfahrungs
begriffe an die seite gestellt
diese bedeuten zwar nicht alle genau
dasselbe sind aber doch dadurch verein
dass sie den herkömmlichen
erfahrungsgemäß konterkarieren der ja
zumindest für die neuzeit in der regel
im rahmen von philosophischen positionen
zentral ist die sich in ihre
methodischen selbstverständnis eng an
das vorbild der naturwissenschaften
anliegen zu denken beispielsweise an den
klassischen aber mehr noch an den
logischen empirismus der vertreter des
sängerkreises adornos spiel sein begriff
der erfahrung immer wieder gegen den in
touristischen strömungen verbreiteten
erfahrungs begriff aus seiner einleitung
zum positivismus streit notiert er ich
zitiere positivismus dokumentiert sich
eine geschichtliche verfassung des
geistes
die erfahrung nicht mehr kennt und darum
sowohl deren rudiment ausrottet wie sich
als ihren ersatz als allein die thieme
form von erfahrung anbieten
die reglemente erfahrung welche der
positivismus verordnet annuliert
erfahrung schaltet der absicht nach das
erfahrende subjekt aus korrelat der
gleichgültigkeit dem objekt gegenüber
ist die beseitigung des objekt ohne
dessen spontane rezept ivi tät doch
nicht objektive zitat eng mit den in
philosophie und wissenschaft
verbreiteten begriff der erfahrung
erläutert adorno mit hilfe des adjektivs
reglementiert und er verwendet dieses
wort um auszudrücken dass der subjekte
erfahrung keine besondere rolle spielt
erfahrung ist etwas was alle in der
gleichen weise machen können und was
immer und überall wiederholen
ganz anders der begriff den adorno uns
dieser bezieht sich auf umgangsweisen
mit der wirklichkeit die unter
besonderer beteiligung der jeweils
betroffenen subjekte stattfinden und die
eben deshalb auch als geistige
erfahrungen angesprochen werden
wenn adorno im zusammenhang mit seinem
es von einem mehr an subjekt spricht
geht es darum zu akzeptieren dass das
subjekt der erfahrung alle seine
möglichkeiten aufruft um sich einer
sache erkennen zu nähern und nicht
unbedacht vorgefertigte begriffe benutzt
den begriff der geistigen erfahrung
sagte ich einmal mehr das utopische
moment von adornos versuch aus dem
gestrüpp der traditionellen erkenntnis
lehrern herauszufinden
es geht darum sich rückhaltlos einer
sache überlassen ohne das gespür für den
eigenen winters erkenntnis objekt zu
verlieren und ohne sich den zugang zu
einem objekt durch den vorschnellen
gebrauch ein spiel der begriffe zu
verschließen
das gebe ich dir darin begrifflichen
konstellationen einzusetzen sodass mit
ihrer hilfe die wirklichkeit in einer
weise beschrieben werden kann
die ihr auf den leib geschneidert in
auch das somatischen moment des geistes
ist im zusammenhang mit adornos begriff
der erfahrung im sinne einer den dingen
angemahnt
erkenntnis relevant er benutzt den
begriff der name geht und er spricht
bezogen auf das meer an subjekt
paradoxerweise auch schon vor etlichen
empfunden oder somatischen momenten mit
dem begriff der mimik wird unter anderem
eine form von erkenntnis angesprochen
die jenseits allgemeiner begriffliche
charakterisierungen einen offenen
zugangs zu den sachen ermöglichen und
sich irgendein stück weit über lässt und
die dinge so darzustellen wie sie sind
wie möglich verhalten soll es
ermöglichen etwas über die dinge zu
erfahren in dem es sich ihnen gleich
beziehungsweise ähnlich macht ein meer
und nicht etwa ein weniger an subjekt
erfordern welche verhaltensweisen da
hier in einem besonderen ausmaß fantasie
sensibilität rezeptiven fähigkeiten
gefordert sind vielleicht ein wenig zu
romantisch richter dollar auch von einer
liebe zu den dingen als modell mädchen
erkennen hier übernimmt sehr viele
überlegungen von benjamin hat modell
genetischen erkennen lässt sich an dem
verhalten von kindern ist er sogar
leblose gegenstände werden nachgeahmt
das kind spielt einen hund spielt einen
stuhl
es macht sich anderen menschen tieren
oder auch dingen ähnlich und ihrem
geheimnis auf die spur zu kommen
in einer vorlesung zur einleitung in die
ecke der theorie aus dem wintersemester
mann 57 58 bemerkt adorno sie zitiere
ich glaube dass wir eigentlich als
kinder alle philosophen sind und dass
uns in der tat durch unsere offizielle
bildung die sich ja immer schon in den
vergebenen stellen lichten branchen-
mäßigen formen abspielt die philosophie
eigentlich aus geprügelt wird und man
könnte in diesem sinne sagen dass
eigentlich überhaupt der versuch sich
ernsthaft mit philosophie abzugeben so
etwas gibt wie ein versuch zur
wiederherstellung der eigenen kindheit
zitat englisch rechte im ethischen
verhalten und eines im positiven sinne
nahen umgangs mit der welt leben in
bestimmten bereichen
neben von erwachsenen fort einer dieser
bereiche ist ja nicht die kunst und eben
deshalb adornos so wichtig um ethische
verhalten gegenüber den dingen in der
welt steht fortwährend neue perspektiven
zur verfügung die dann in begriffliche
konstellationen eingepasst werden können
welche unsere sicht der welt erweitern
wie ihn ethisches verhalten und das
einfügen von begriffen in
konstellationen als zwei modi operandi
des geistes ineinander greifen wie
somatische impuls und begriffliche
aktivität zusammentreten
wer freilich genauer nach zu zeigen zu
den bedingungen der möglichkeit von
kinetischer erkenntnis gehört eine
ähnlichkeit oder verwandtschaft zwischen
erkennen im subjekt und erkennen im
objekt auf die ähnlichkeit stößt ordnung
wenn er gegen den die realistischen
begriff zugleich auf die so massiv wie
texte geistes und seine gebundenheit als
materielle hinweis der menschliche leid
tragen alle fähigkeiten mit geissen
hinein und stellt ein kompliment für
materialität der dinge dar
so gesehen ist es gerade der nicht
unabhängig vom vergesellschaften und
sinnlich offizier barren individuum zu
verstehende geist der neue geist adornos
der mimetischen erkennen ermöglicht und
wer das medium von erfahrung im
emphatischen sinne dies auf der
grundlage seiner leiblichen verfasstheit
kann sich der geist ein gegenständliches
angleichen
im letzten zeit meines vortrags möchte
ich nur dann kurz einige diskussions von
texten aus der neueren philosophie des
geistes aufgerufen auf die sich adornos
überlegungen beziehen lassen
adorno und die neuere philosophie
begleitet adorno verwendet zweifellos
ein ganz anderes vokabular als es
heutzutage in der philosophie des
geistes aber auch in der
erkenntnistheorie übliche der sache nach
lassen sich seine überlegungen die doch
durchaus auf eine reihe von problemen
aus der aktuellen diskussion beziehen
sind
unter von einer erstaunlichen aktualität
denken wir an die in der gegenwärtigen
erkenntnistheorie diskutierte frage nach
dem verhältnis von professional nicht
proposition aale erkenntnis oder an die
frage nach dem begrifflichen gehalt der
vernehmung beziehungsweise erfahrung
denken wir an die debatte um einen
sozialen extremismus in der philosophie
der sprache beziehungsweise des geistes
oder an die diskussionen über den
verkörperten geist und soziale kognition
zu erwähnen ist auch der streit und die
reduzierte des subjektiven in der
debatte über quali adorno hat zu allen
diesen fragen etwas zu sagen ich will
lediglich am beispiel zweier fragen
skizzieren wie sie ja dort beiträge in
eine beziehung zu heute diskutierten
fragestellungen bringen lassen
seit mehr als 30 jahren zeigt gerne in
seinem buch bereit ist referent die
unterscheidung zwischen nicht
begrifflich im gehalt und begrifflichen
gehalt eingeführt hat gibt es eine weit
verzweigte überaus komplexe mitunter
auch ein wenig schulak debatte über die
frage ob der inhalt der wahrnehmung bzw
erfahrung begrifflich ist oder aber ob
das nicht der fall ist
die meisten wären dieser debatte
beteiligten personen die sogenannte
neuen konzept zur listen die davon
ausgehen dass die inhalte der
wahrnehmung oder erfahrung als solche
mit begriffs sehnt und erst durch die
anwendung von begriff in dem urteil eine
begriffliche struktur erhalten
eine solche position wird etwa von
künstler vertreten andere minderheit
gehen davon aus dass bereits der gehalt
der wahrnehmung wo der erfahrung als
solcher begrifflich ist viel diskutiert
in den letzten jahren wurde insbesondere
die position von john macdougall er
votiert dafür dass der gehalt von
erfahrungen deshalb griffig sein muss
weil erfahrungen in rechtfertigung zu
sammen hängen eine rolle spielen
in rechtfertigung zusammenhängen kann
aber nur eine rolle spielen was
seinerseits begrifflich ist und in dem
von mcgowan im anschluss an fehler so
genannten raum der gründe gehört mit
dauernd spricht daher von einer
unbegrenzt
die begrifflichen also genau genommen
spricht er von der anbau mit
man sollte das aber nicht mit
ungebundenheit übersetzung sondern der
sache nach der mit ungewissheit weil die
these die sich dahinter verbirgt ist
wurde wie das alles im leben von wesen
die über begriffe verfügen immer schon
begrifflich strukturiert ja ich würde
hier von einem apriori der artikulation
reden mit seinem manöver möchte mcdowell
zwei positionen vermeiden
die aus seiner sicht in der gleichen
weise verstehe sind einen kohärent ismus
der sich nur im reich der begriffe
bewegt ohne auf die welt rücksicht zu
nehmen und einen funktionalismus
foundation im englischen wird im
deutschen häufig mit fundamentalismus
übersät ist aber ein wenig irreführend
denn sollte man von funktionalismus
sagen und also einem von nationalismus
der unkritisch von der idee von etwas
gegebenem ausgeht und die konstellation
philosophische spielzüge die mcdowell
hier im blick hat und vermeiden möchte
ich im grunde dieselbe idee die adorno
diskutiert wenn er den idealistischen
primates objekt mit einem
materialistischen vorrang des objekt zu
vermitteln versucht die nähe zwischen
beiden vermittlungsversuchen kann ich
überraschung denn zwei der philosophen
auf dieses mcdowell häuser der beziehung
sind kant und hegel
freilich geht adorno viel weiter als mit
der die abhängigkeit philosophischer
betrifft von der geschichte in den blick
nimmt und die erkenntnistheorie auf
gesellschaft theoretisch informierte
weise überschreiten möchte
außerdem hat seine konzeption am ende
einen brüchigen charakter und adorno
gehen auch nicht davon aus dass sich die
von ihm in aussicht gestellte positionen
einfach im sinne eines standpunktes
präsentieren lässt adorno macht er mit
seiner eigenen ansichten
ich zitiere philosophie nur dort noch
mehr als bloßer betrieb ist wo sie den
totalen mit denen sich exponiert zitat
ende
während mitgliedsbeiträge die belange
sind gewiss nicht in frage stellen das
meine ich den kontext gar nicht kritik
sondern einfach nur feststellen
kommen wir zum zweiten problem ich hatte
ja gesagt spieler zwei problemen als
versuchen hat ozzy neuere debatte zu
beziehen die ersten arbeiten zur frage
nach der identität des subjektiven
innerhalb der neueren sowie des geistes
liegen mehr als 40 jahre und sogar noch
länger zurück
konvertieren siebziger thomas mergel
einen aufsatz mit dem titel wurde sind
leicht zu bierwerth veröffentlicht in
dem er sich dafür stark macht dass der
subjektive charakter der erfahrung durch
keine reduziere analyse des bewusstseins
oder des greifen verschafft werden kann
gab sachen das bewusstsein reisende
zumute sein
so lege die subjektive tatsachen der
verfassung und beschreibung von einem
naturwissenschaftlichen standpunkt auf
nicht möglich ist und die nicht auf
musikalischen sachverhalte reduzierbar
sind im ergebnis scheint diese regel
eine lücke aus zu tun müssen der
persönlichen erfahrung eine zumute sein
und ihrer objektiven physikalischen
erklärung aus der perspektive der
dritten person oder der physik riesig in
einer deutschen position liegende
zufolge darin dass sich eine dual it
geschichte dinge auf trend und die
auffassung begünstigt wird dass die
geist begaben subjekte die eine
innenperspektive auf sich einnehmen
können von nichts anderem als von sich
selbst abhängen
fotos formuliert ein richtig verstandene
reduktionismus kann zu einem falschen
humanismus führen und auf der
voraussetzung dass man entweder
reduktion ist oder du liest sein und bei
deren regal meter von analytischer
literatur die seit nägel zum teil auch
schon vorher zu der frage publiziert
worden sind ob es phänomenales
bewusstsein gibt ob es diese woche die
deutsche zustände reduzieren will
und um aus der skizzierten schwierigkeit
reduktionismus oder dualismus
herauszukommen um aus dieser
schwierigkeit herauszukommen wurden und
werden mitunter überaus noch viele
winkelsweg getätigt man denke an den
anomalen und es muss und an super wenn
jens theorien geist als varianten einem
instruktiven natürlich
auch auf diese thematik lässt sich mit
den augen hatte und er würde gar nicht
erst versuchen den begriff des
phänomenalen bewusstsein oder der
subjektiven erfahrung mit einem nicht
realistischen ansatz der letzte so viele
gäste zu verwöhnen sondern darauf
aufmerksam machen dass bereits die
ausgangslage der problemstellung tief
ist der geist ist nämlich nicht einfach
etwas das gegen die welt gehört oder
außerhalb der feld steht sondern der
geist tut etwas was ihn aus ganz
grundsätzliche weise von den dingen
unterscheidet deren bewegungen gänzlich
im kausalen bahnen verlaufen geist ist
eine aktivität die in erster linie hat
ausübung von fähigkeiten bis erkennen
und handeln angesehen werden kann
das ist ein thema welches die möglichen
debatten zum geist körper problem
allenfalls am rande auftaucht diese
debatten beruhen auf voraussetzungen die
sie gar nicht durchschauen und derzeit
auch nicht zu thematisieren können
adorno bemerkt die kontroverse über die
priorität von geist und körper erfährt
vor dialektisch beide geist und körper
sind abstraktionen von ihrer erfahrung
ihre radikale differenz ist ein
gesetztes zitat ende
menschen erfahren sich als einen
zusammenhang von geist und körper in
einer lebendigen natur
sie erfahren durch als ein stück natur
es waren aber gleichzeitig dass sie
nicht ausschließlich natur sind in
manchen neueren diskussionen wird von
solchen erfahrungen abgesehen und da
wird verkannt dass geist und natur in
einem bestimmten sinne auf dieselbe
seite gehören und trotzdem nicht
aufeinander reduziert werden können
das ist sicher ein grund dafür warum auf
der grundlage von materialistischen
ansätzen in der philosophie des geistes
vorstellen für einen determinismus
optiert reale erinnern mich an die
debatten vor einigen jahren darüber ob
nicht so wie wir vor dem zweiten gang
dass wir in freising mit seinem begriff
zeit und ich komme zum schluss an adorno
eine denken
seit eröffnen welche eingefahren
gegenüberstellungen hinter sich lässt
und auch weit entfernt vom heute
üblichen kompatibel ist
ich zitiere madonna schreibt der
widerspruch von freiheit und
determinismus ist einer der
selbsterfahrung der subjekte waldfreibad
unfrei zitat ende
einmal mehr zeigt sich die enge
verbindung von geistes- und freiheits
lehre die einen blut kern von adornos
philosophieren aufmacht ich bedanke mich
wieder auf gefolgt